speaking of ridiculous boy the Segways
are writing themselves today
MSNBC this week after John fetterman
beat Dr Oz may God have mercy on
Pennsylvanian Souls they actually had a
panel discussing whether John fetterman
might be up to being president in 2024.
a nominee at some point for president
um I know there's some variables
obviously but it's just a few but I just
you know
what he did in the in the super red deep
red parts of Pennsylvania and the way
that he ran ahead of Biden as you were
saying around ahead of trump I mean it
just makes it makes you wonder about his
future
that woman her name is Katie tur I
believe should have been removed from
the room during live television they
should have put her in a straight jacket
and just outright removed her sorry lady
even for this network that is a bit much
the fact that they sat there and
discussed that is completely insane you
know you could tell they were sort of
laughing through it but the fact that
this guy is even in Senate is is just
nuts Katy tur should just be removed and
taken away